[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre rendez-vous
récurrent sur la photo avec notre
photographe à nous claud chose bonjour
bonjouratrice photographe et puis vous
courrez les les exp
dans et comme à chaque fois il y a un
invité avec un thème et cet invité c'est
Patrick HUG bonjour bonjour Patrice vous
êtes photograp et vous êtes spécialiste
si je peux dire du droit à l'image et on
va parler avec vous du droit à l'image
alors y a des livres évidemment qui sont
consacrés à ça et c'est très important
un mot claud sur sur Patrick qui est
photographe aussi vous le disiez je le
disais c'est plutôt photographe de
studio c'est ça alors c'est ça Patrick
c'est un passionné je précise bien
passionné de studio comme moi je suis
passionné de de rue mais Patrick fait
beaucoup de de choses il a vous sortez
il rentre lui voilà c'est ça lui c'est à
l'intérieur il choisit des modèles avec
qui il travaille d'ailleurs le droit à
l'image s'applique sur son travail bien
sûr bien il s'applique sur tous les
travaux je pense pH vu Patrice qui a
travaillé chez Renault donc et qui s'est
occupé de ce de cette organisation
photographique qui avait donc au siège
Renault à guyancour et c'est comme ça
que on a j'ai pu mieux le connaître et
surtout connaître son travail sur le
droit d'image travail et pour moi ça
reste globalement les conférences de
Patrick restent quelque chose de de de
de d'essentiel pour que les photographes
ne commettent pas d'erreurs se mettent
pas en porte à fou avec ce qu'on trouve
dans le public VO patri pourquoi
d'ailleurs vous êtes passionné pour le
pour le droit à l'image donc c'est un
peu comment dire c'est un peu par hasard
en fait j'ai rencontré Joël verbrug
justement l'avocate oui au Salon de la
Photo il y a quelques années qui est
photographe aussi ououi il y a quelques
années 7 7 ans à peu près et puis je me
souviens de l'avoir interpellé je l'ai
croisé dans dans le dans les couloirs
dans les allées et en lui disant que bah
j'avais relevé quelques coquilles dans
un de ses ouvrages elle avait fait un
ouvrage sur le droit à la photo c'est
elle a fait elle a fait énormément
d'ouvrages sur le droit et l'image le
droit et l'image donc les endroits où se
rencontre le droit et l'image d'acord et
donc sur un de ces ouvrages j'avais
relevé quelques codquill et puis bon je
m'attendais à avoir un accueil un peu
mitigé quand vous interpoz quelqu'un de
connu et en fait non et puis bah la
discussion c'est que quand vous écrivez
quelque chose vous-même et que vous vous
relisez
vous relisez ce que vous avez voulu
écrire et pas forcément ce que vous avez
écrit c'est intéressant ou donc c'est
pour ça que ou souvent les éditeurs il y
a des relcteurs pas toujours un peu
moins maintenant exactement donc avec
cette accroche en fait on a commencé à
discuter puis la discussion enfin on
s'est trouvé pas mal d'atomes crochus et
donc on est amis donc vous avez
sympathisé soyez partis pour l'attaquer
voilà et ce qui fait que depuis elle
publie donc dans
deux maisons d'éditions différentes euh
cette maison d'édition à Pillon sur rue
très très connu c'est les éditions
nowhere qui dépendent du magazine
Compétence Photo c'est le même
responsable d'accord voilà et puis elle
fait un certain nombre d'ouvrages
qu'elle veut plus facile plus aborda et
ces ouvrages là c'est moi qui en fait la
relecture depuis plus de 5 ans alors
vous avez sympathisé maintenant et dit
bah parce que vous trouvez des coquilles
voilà
exactement voilà et Laure et donc vous
êtes devenu une sorte de spécialiste du
droit à l'image du voilà par de fait par
cette
relation je ne suis absolument pas
juriste simplement j'ai pu au fil de ses
écrits et puis de discussions aussi
d'approfondissement avec elle euh
comprendre un certain nombre de choses
et donc pendant toute ma carrière on va
dire de photographe un peu engagé en
tant que responsable d'un club photo
justement au Technocentre
Renault responsable de de la partie
studio j'ai toujours eu à cœur de de
faire monter les gens de faire en sorte
qu'il qu'ils progressent et même si je
ne suis pas le meilleur le petit peu
d'avance que j'ai dont je suis sûr je
tiens à le faire partager c'est bien ne
gardez pas ça pour vous je ne garde pas
ça pour moi et ce qui fait que
d'ailleurs ça amène des sentiments un
petit peu mitigés puisque il y a des
photographes que à qui j'ai apporté des
choses au début et qui font des photos
nettement meilleur que les miennes donc
c'est à la fois un côté oui c'est ça
vous acceptez de dépasser voilà voilà
c'est un M mais ça fait parti passionû
alors parlons de ce ce droit à l'IM le
le le principe quand même c'est que
quand on est photographier quand on est
le sujet d'e d'une photo il faut il faut
donner son accord alors le principe dans
la loi le droit à l'image n'existe pas
d'accord
ah c'est une construction qu'on appelle
jurisprudentielle c'est-à-dire que le
droit à l'image il découle de l'article
9 du code civil qui dit tout simplement
chacun a droit au respect à sa vie
privée sa vie privée c'est le respect de
la vie privée absolument et là c'est
l'intégralité de de du paragraphe majeur
de cet AR si quelqu'un me photographie
sans mon consentement c'est une atteinte
à ma vie privée en gros c'est ça c'est
ça hein et alors comme pour chaque chose
chaque acte dans la vie on a des droits
qui s'opposent donc on a le respect de
notre vie privée qui qui est un statut
reconnu mais il y a aussi des libertés
fondamentales qui sont exprimées dans
différents textes au niveau européen
français comme la liberté d'expression
et le droit à
l'information donc le plus souvent le
droit à l'image c'est-à-dire le droit
d'une personne à disposer de
l'utilisation de son image de sa propre
imageage euh peut être mis en en balance
par rapport au droit à la liberté enfin
au droit d'expression du phot artistique
le plus souvent dans le dans les les
cadres qui nous intéressent ou euh le
droit à l'information alors quand il
s'agit par exemple de vous journaliste
d'accord alors on va peut-être serrir
les questions parce que je pense qu'il
faut alors commençons par le par le le
premier enfin le premier conflit un peu
entre le droit à à la vie privée et le
la liberté d'expression euh puisque
voilà c'est de bon par exemple alors ça
ça pose pour pour Claude qui
photographie beaucoup dans la
rue vous photographiez trouvez un
quelque chose d' extraordinaire vous
photographiez
euh est-ce que ça suffit de dire bah
c'est ma liberté d'expression pour que
pour pouvoir publier la photo de
n'importe qui en pratique oui ah oui oui
tout à fait par contre
euh le problème il est c'est que au
moment alors il faut bien distinguer
deux choses le le le droit à l'image il
s'applique il va se revendiquer au
moment de la diffusion de la photo et
pas au moment de la prise de vue prise
oui c'est oui oui prise de vue à la
limite vous vous en foutez si personne
ne voit la photo exactement et si vous
ne savez pas encore ce que vous allez
faire de la photo au moment où vous la
prenez la consigne général de toute
façon pour les photographes c'est prenez
la photo euh et posez-vous la question
le moment de se poser la question ça
sera au moment où vous aurez envie de la
publier oua puisque c'est le diffuseur
qui est responsable du respect du droit
à
l'image pas le photographe c'est pas
forcément c'est pas forcément si
photograph par exemple c'est le le
directeur de la publication oui sauf que
le directeur de la publication il a déjà
des imprimés et il vous demande de le
décharger de ce droit donc la loi fait
que c'est lui le responsable et lui son
moyen technique c'est de se reposer sur
vous d'cord donc il faut bien faire
attention à ça quand vous avez par
exemple quelqu'un qui veut publier une
de vos
expositions si on s'il y a un minimum de
risque c'est celui qui va organiser
l'exposition qui a donc diffusé qui est
responsable du respect de ce droit à
l'image ce droit à l'image il est pas
absolu parce que comme je disais il y a
une une opposition de droit avec la
liberté d'expression supposons que voilà
on photographie Claude avec sa maîtresse
euh tout à fait mais c'est c'est le dans
une rue et qu'on publie cette photo je
comprends qu'il soit pas content alors
il faudra encore prouver par exemple que
ça a posé un problème soit lui-même soit
à sa maîtresse que ça a été la
il faut qu' a préjudice il faut qu'il a
un préjudice il faut qu'il ait le seul
fait d'être photographié même si vous
tenez pas à ce que la photo soit publiée
ne suffit pas ne suffit pas même si vous
dites mais mais oui enfin moi j'ai pas
envie qu'on qu'on publie ma savoir vivre
va vous va vous faire peser le pour et
le contre mais pas la loi c'estd que si
on publie une photo de quelqu'un sans
son consentement supposant dans un
journal il n'a il n'a pas de recours
alors tout dépend des circonstances même
si ça lui porte pas de préjudice tout
dépend des circonstance dans un journal
ça ne pose pas de problème euh tant que
on ne crée pas de de préjudice donc par
exemple un une des affaires qui était
souvent cité c'est Antenne 2 qui faisait
un comment dire un un reportage sur un
match de rugby et puis pas très loin
dans la foule il y avait un personnage
très exubérantle très reconnaissable à
l'image il se trouve que ce personnage
il était en congé maladie et donc il
n'était pas censé se trouver
là son patron a vu le
reportage et il a été licencié pour
faute professionnelle grave à cause de
ça ouais il là il a pu démontrer le
préjudice et bien que lui soi-même soit
lui-même dans une condition on va dire
un petit peu ambigu et bien il a emporté
le le droit il a emporté le jugement et
Antenne 2 a dû lui verser des DOM inérê
des indemnit il y a eu un film aussi sur
ça ave patri Smith et euh comment il
s'appelle Vincent Lindon où justement il
était gardien de squir et il devait
travailler ce jour-là il il assiste à un
match de de football et ça passe à
l'antenne et donc il est viré alors il
parce que pardon mais il y avait il me
semble qu'il y avait une décision comme
ça à Roland Garos où il y avait un
justement un un un type qui était enfin
quelqu'un qui était là avec avec sa
maîtresse je crois et et il est filmé
dans l'assistance de l'orgarous et il
avait fait un procès je crois qu'il
avait perdu parce que il était dans un
lieu dit public alors normalement là il
faudrait avoir la les attendus complets
du jugement mais ça ne suffit pas en
fait c'est sur c'est très probablement
parce qu'il n'a pas réussi à démontrer
la gravité du préjudice qui était causé
d'accord parce que le fait d'être dans
un lieu public où il y a cand vousz sur
centr vous saz qu'il y a des caméras et
un moment vous pouvez être pris par
l'image ENF vous voilà bien sûr bien sûr
donc ça vous le savez je dire c'est pas
pareil que si vous êtes dans pardon dans
la rue vous êtes en train de marcher
vous êtes pas censé être photographié
voyez ce que je veux dire tout à fait
mais on est on est aussi dans une
relation de lieu publique là avec un
lieu public donc les la loi s'applique
indifféremment à partir du moment où où
le lieu est public justement d'accord la
rue est un lieu public si on voit vient
vous photographier chez vous euh dans
votre
lit avec qui vous voulez là c'est une
violation de la vie privée et en plus là
il y a un article particulier du du Code
civil qui comment dire du code pénal
pardon qui protège ce ce genre de chose
c'est-à-dire que on n' pas le droit de
là de filmer ou enregistrer oui vous
êtes chez vous sauf quand c'est fait au
vue de tous et que il n'y a pas eu de de
ha qui a été mis à la prise de vue lors
de la prise de est-ce que la la
personnalité des gens photographiés ou
filmés importe c'estàd que est-ce que le
la vie privée
d'un personne lambda est la même que
celle d'une d'une star de la chanson du
cinéma dans un lieu publi c'est une
question un petit peu piège parce qu'en
fait pour donner pour donner la la
comparaison pour pouvoir donner deux
éventualités
imaginez une personnalité publique qui
part en famille se reposer sur un
endroit qui ne convoque absolument pas
la presse et qui se fait photographier
en maillot de bain sur la plage et bien
elle aura le droit d'attaquer sans aucun
problème les les éventuels photographes
qui prendront des photos paradis et on
ne sait pas s'ils sont là ou pas là
enfin je dire c'est pas vous vois pas
même pas les gens par contre la même
personnalité publique qui va soi-disant
prendre des vacances pour aller visiter
des installations et que elle en profite
pour y passer de semaines si les
photographes reviennent il s'agit d'un
sujet d'information là en disant voyez
Intel a passé 15 jours au frais de la
princesse à un endroit où il était pas
censé par
exemple c'est vous qui le dites voilà et
donc là dans ce cas-là en terme de de
jugement on aura vraiment deux choses
totalement différentes et pour des
personnes des personnalités connu public
donc après pour le le mais en en sur le
principe le le le droit à l'image des
personnes non non célèbr et des
personnes célèbres et le même presque
presque alors après si on parle cette
fois-ci des artistes ou des sportifs il
y a des cas particuliers là qui sont
autre à une autre étape que le comment
dire qu'on appelle les dro voisins
c'est-à-dire que eux ils ont confié leur
image par exemple à des agents et donc
la publication non volontaire non voulue
d'une de leurs photos va créer un manque
à gagner par rapport à leur activité et
donc dans ce cas-là ils sont en mesure
de démontrer un préjudice sous forme de
manque à gagner ouais il y av d'ailleurs
il y a eu un conflit enfin c'est un
problème particulier avec le par ex
Mbappé avec l'équipe de France de
football sur le droit à l'image voilà il
vouit contrôler de savoir pourquoi on
utilisait ex et après tout ils ont bien
raison deouirler donc dans les pardon
dans les effectivement euh dans les
comment dire dans les prétextes on va
dire le droit à l'image couvre
essentiellement je recherche mon c'est
les les différents items qui sont
atteintes au respect à la vie privée
donc là c'est le premier niveau mais il
y a après la diffamation il y a
l'atteinte à la dignité humaine et
l'atteinte à des droits patrimoniaux de
l'image du une personnalité publique
d'accord euh dans le cas de de Mbappé il
y avait comment dire des il ne
souhaitait pas que son image soit
associée à des logos ou à des marques à
des causes qui qu' pour lesquells ne les
reconnaît pas et donc là c'est une des
raisons qui peut faire que l'on peut
s'attaquer justement à la diffusion
d'une
image tu as le est-ce que le cas de de
François Marie bagier
rentre nous en François Mar c'était le
c'était c'est un photographe c'est un
photographe c'était voilà il était très
connu il a été condamné dans dans
l'affaire
bcourcours mais il a été il y avait un
procès il y a eu un procès donc en 2008
qui a marqué l'histoire de de la
photographie enfin du droit à l'image
justement jusqu'au début des années 2000
la justice était très prompte à
condamner les photographes qui
diffusaient des images justement qui
pour lesquelles qui n'avait pas demandé
d'autorisation de diffusion à leur au
sujet qui pouvait être présenté d' et il
a publié un livre où il mettait en en
exerg la différence qui peut exister
d'entre des niveaux de vie euh comment
dire différent de ce qui voilà donc sur
une double page il y avait d'un côté un
un SDF qui était allongé sous un Porsche
avec ses cartons son son sac de couchage
et sur l'autre page on voyait un ban
public avec une personne très comment
dire très classe on va dire très chic
avec son petit chien qui était qui avait
son petit manteau voilà et il mettait le
contraste entre les deux personnes la
personne s'est reconnue et a jugé
dégradante de de la situation dans
laquelle elle se trouvait dans ce livre
et en fait il a gagné son procès parce
que justement la personne n'a pas été en
mesure de démontrer que ça lui créé un
préjudice
matériel d'une façon d'une gravité telle
que qu'il fallait s'en offusquer
donc ce cet arrêté de juillet 2008 a
marqué un tournant et on va dire que
maintenant la justice regarde beaucoup
plus pondère beaucoup plus les droits en
balance et sauf quelques exceptions on a
des des jugements qui sont assez
équilibrés et qui ne sont pas
toujoursord inéressant par c'est que en
matière de télévision c'est qu'il
fallait toujours de demander les les
autorisations des gens qui passent
l'antenne al en matière de télévision à
partir du moment où il y a enfin comment
dire on a une publication commerciale
euh normalement c'est obligatoire pour
tout ce qui peut être une utilisation
commerciale soit sur des objets support
soit sur de la publicité il est
indispensable d'avoir l'accord écrit
préalablement à la diffusion pas
forcément à la prise de vue puis
évidemment tout dépend aussi de de de à
quoi sert une photo il y a il y a
probablement des différences entre euh
les photos de artistiques enfin par
exemple Claude quand vous faites des
photos dans la rue vous demandez
toujours l'autorisation hein et puis des
photos journalistiques qui sont peuvent
être un peu volé à un moment et voilà et
donc il y a effectivement une une
frontière très marqué avec deux comment
dire deux corpus de lois très différents
qui s'appliquent diff liberté de
d'expression artistique déjà la durée de
prescription c'est-à-dire le la personne
qui se reconnaît à 5 ans pour réagir 5
ans à partir du moment où elle devrait
savoir que c'est publié voilà dans le le
droit à l'information c'est 3 mois
c'est-à-dire vous avez 3 mois pour
pouvoir réagir et au bout de 3 mois il y
a prescription et et c'est passé d'ord
en en liberté artistique pardon en droit
d'information ce qui va intervenir c'est
si par exemple on publie une photo qui
est hors contexte vous faites un je sais
pas un reportage sur sur la marche des
fierté et puis la photo qui accompagne
représente un couple mais qui aurait été
pris 3 ans avant comme c'est pas une
photo qui a été prise lors de cette
Marche des
fiertés les personnes peuvent dire moi
j'ai tiré un trait là-dessus je
veux et donc ou droit l'oubli qui est
important aussi je ne veux pas que que
cette photo soit et donc là voilà ce qui
va intervenir dans le
côté droit à l'information c'est
passionnant patri je je vais on y
reviendra avec grand plaisir mais il
faut qu'on laisse un peu de place à
claud Paris juste attention il nous
reste 5 minutes hein Claude donc si vous
voulez parler de photo oui bon écoute je
voulais juste dire que j'ai été un jour
interpellé par des jeunes dans le parc
de Versailles je faisait une photo ils
étaient dessus ils ont appelé la police
et la police est venue vérifier mon
identité et la police leur a dit mais
monsieur chose il a le droit de faire
les photos qu'il veut tout dépense qu'il
va en publier donc ça rejoint bien ce
que vient de nous dire
donc voilà un mot 2 secondes 2 secondes
je voulais remercier Joel verbrug qui m
fourni tout tout le le matériau la
source et qui a accepté hier soir de
relire ma présentation donc voilà c'est
voilà c'est gagnant gagnant c'est de
deux côtés exact donc Claude alors
quelqu quelques mots sur des expos
photos on va on va commencer par
évidemment c'est un événement chaque
année mais qui qui est clou c'est Paris
Photo Paris Photo donc déjà je situe
Paris photo se passe toujours au mois de
novembre puisque le mois de novembre à
Paris c'est c'est le Mois de la Photo
donc j'y suis allé cette année comme j'y
vais tous les ans parce que je trouve
que c'est toujours très intéressant d'
les voir et cette année il y avait 191
galeries qui en font de ce salon
certainement un des plus grands salons
photographiques de au monde et et tout
particulièrement en France alors vous
avez vous avez voilà il y a quelqu
photos donc il y a chaque
galerie montre des des choses
différentes dans donc dans ce lieu donc
qui se passe au Grand Palais éphémère
donc là c'est une photo de Marc Ribou
donc que l'on voit Marc Ribou qui est un
éminent photographe qui a d'ailleurs
cédé son fond photographique à la France
au musé Guill il y avait aussi du
Michael Kena Michael Kena qui est aussi
un photographe anglais qui a donné son
son fond photographique à à la France
donc la transaction est en train de se
passer est-ce qu'il un thème non par
photo ce sont les galerie qui viennent
du monde entier parce que tu vois vous
voyez vous avez aussi bien des photos de
France des galeries françaises que
espagnol que allemand donc c'est
vraiment une un grand moment de
photographie donc on y voit beaucoup de
choses et je trouve que quand on aime la
photo il faut aller voir
malheureusementné il faut attendre ça
voyez c'est Michael Ken donc qui fait
fait qui était exposé à la caméra obscur
donc voilà alors vous disiez le mois de
novembre c'est le Mois de la Photo euh
alors on va passer à d'autres
expositions qu'on peut voir qu'on peut
voir encore donc vous avez corps à
corore à beauourgour on en avait déjà
parlé la la lors de l'émission
précédente moi je conseille aux gens
d'aller voir donc cette collection
puisque c'est les collections de
beauourg et de Monsieur euh marin carnix
c'est c'est quelque chose qui est à voir
si vous voulez donc ça on voit euh euh
ja jacometti si vous voulez donc qui est
qui est un photographe qui est décédé
malheureusement et euh vous avez aussi
donc euh bien sur la photo noir et blanc
à la BNF François mitteran je précise al
bobour c'est ça s'appelle Corac cor cor
noir et blanc c'est à la BNF François
miter voilà alors ça c'est une photo
form ça il faut y aller moi j'y suis
allé dimanche il y avait une tris quart
d'heure d'attente j'ai battu en retraite
alors ça ce sont des photos de les deux
photos précédentes c'était hamsel Adams
qui est quand même un grand nom de la
photo américaine mais aussi mondiale là
c'est une photo de manery si vous voulez
ou elle est connue C elle est très conn
mais bon j'ai voulu la montrer parce que
ça ça vaut ça vaut le coup puis ça c'est
une photo qui est plus blanche d' d'un
d'un artiste dont j'ai oublié le nom
mais que que je trouve assez super alors
ça cette photo moi j'adore cette photo
elle est d'ailleurs été exposée à
Versailles c'est kthèz KS c'est le
balcon de la Martinique cette photo
quand vous la regardez elle attire
l'attention qu'est-ce qu' montre
pourquoi qui c'est cette ombre qu'on
voit derrière donc on s'interroge
beaucoup en voyant cette cette cette
photographie donc euh donc ça c'est à
c'est à la Bibliothèque François
mitteran François mitteran donc ça
s'appelle noir et blanc et c'est encore
quelques quelques temps hein voilà c'est
ça je suis au mois de janvier euh début
février mes souvenir sont pu Erwin Pen
il est toujours là Erwin Pen est
toujours là alors Erwin pen on connait
le le fameux portrait de Picasso de Jean
cocto et cetera je trouve que c'est
c'est vraiment un grand nom de la photo
c'est la suite de l'exposition qui s'est
passé au Francis àville et qu'il faut
absolument aller VO Picasso je parle de
Doville il faut si vous avez l'occasion
d'aller à à daauville il faut aller voir
planche contact on va pas se
compliqu va pas si loinors c'est la
galerie Tadou à Paris qui qui est dans
le 4e 3e dans le 3è et puis sur le quai
de la photo donc j'avais déjà parlé de
cette de cette nouvelle installation de
cette barge une barge avec des
expositions qui ch
voilà donc c'est absolument génial et
puis euh et puis je pense que ah ou
est-ce que je voulez dire si vousz et il
y a quelques expositions dans les
evvelines dans les evvelines vous avez
ce weekend weekend du 18 donc à hencour
c'est l'association photographique
d'élencour soit fait les 50 ans
d'existence et donc retrace tout le
trajet qu'ils ont fait montre des photos
tous les invités qu'ils ont reçu et
montrre des photos qui sont très
intéressantes donc moi je vous invite à
aller voir sur encour et puis il y a
aussi aussi comment il y a aussi au
chîné qui expose comme tous les 2 ans la
Bienale de la Bienale photographique de
du chaînet que c'est ça commence ce
weekend donc si le vernissage c'est
samedi si vous voulez voir un coup il
faut aller là-bas et
euh si tu veux tu il y a pas de problème
si vous voulez il y a pas de problème
moi j'y serai j'ai été invité donc voilà
et puis et puis vous avez si vous aimez
flanner dans Paris il y a Paris Paris
Photo enfin photoint-germain vous allez
entre les les dans les rues donc enfit
non dans les galeries qui sont rue de
Scine et rue Mazarine donc vous allez
voir plein de comme il y a beaucoup de
galeries il présentent des photos donc
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire photo
est vivante la photo vit et bon avec
avec vous Patrice on pourra faire des
des des prochaines émissions pour
montrer des des grands des photographes
amateurs qui se passionn pour la
photograie merci beaucoup Claude je vous
remercie Pat merci beaucoup Patric merci
beaucoup et bah on reviendra parce que
c'est un c'est un sujet peut-être qu'on
fera des choses un peu ponctuel parce
que c'est intéressant de parce que si on
est très vaste évidemment c'est un peu
plus compliqué mais pour le traiter par
chapitre par chapitre voilà par chapit
parce que Patrice euh Patrick il a
vraiment beaucoup de de remarques
pertinentes moi quand j'ai besoin d'une
je dois répondre à une question vous
appelez Patrick j'appelle Patrick donc
voilà et puis donner son numéro de
téléphone ioulais aussi que pour les
gens qui pourra être intéressés par
Paris pH il y a il y a un lien
photographique un lien internet qui vous
permet d'aller voir de revisiter les
galeries donc voilà ça peut être
intéressant Paris Photo merci beaucoup
claud merci beaucoup Patrick très vite
pour un nouveau rendez-vous
photo